prayers to the family or those who lost
their life today
Tommy Elliott
63 years of age
Jim Tutt
64 years of age
Josh Barrett
40 years of age and Juliana farmer
57.
we have a total of nine victims who were
treated
and are being treated at a university
the Louisville Hospital
three which are in critical condition
including our officer three who are
listed in non-critical condition and
three who have been treated and released
the two officers who struck in exchange
have gone fire one of the officers he
was raised to the left side and the
other officer suffered minor injuries to
the Elbow
I just want to let everyone know that
the officer who is in critical condition
today
officer Nicholas wilt
26 years of age
just graduated from the police academy
on March 31st
I just swore him in and his family was
there to witness his journey to become a
police officer
he was struck
in the head
engaged in this incident
Nick has come out of brain surgery
and is in critical but stable condition
as we speak
I've been down there with the family and
given my love and support
been with all the families today to show
our love and support for them and if
anything else that they need from lmpd
we will provide that
the next few days are important and very
critical for Nicholas's recovery
this will be a long complex
investigation involving local state and
our federal Partners I'll be remiss if I
did not acknowledge our federal Partners
who have just been just outstanding our
local partners
ATF FBI
I thank you our local Partners
University of Louisville Police
EMS Emergency Management Services
thank you thank you for everything and
for my lmpd officers
who took it upon themselves and not wait
to assess everything but just went in to
stop the threat so that more lives would
not be lost
thank you
thank you for showing up
even when sometimes you are just felt
like you're not appreciated but I asked
my officers when I addressed them today
if we don't do it who will
and so they're very committed in their
resiliency show today and their
professionalism show today I want to
thank the governor I want to thank the
mayor who has been with us every step of
the way through this trying and critical
time
but I want to encourage the public
if you have any additional information
please call 574 lmpd and assist us
this should not continue to happen
evil should not
try to Prevail and take over our city
and we let it happen
so I'm encouraging everybody that we
United and that we continue to do the
good work and lmpd will continue to keep
this community in this city safe
thank you very much chief
today is a day that's heartbreaking for
our city
for all of us
and especially for the people who are in
that office
at Old National Bank
and their loved ones
we just heard the chief Give the names
of the people who lost their lives
in this mass shooting this morning
one of them
Tommy Elliott
a very good friend of mine
of the governors
Tommy's family
to the families of Jim Tutt
Josh Barrick
Julianna farmer
Rachel and I join you
families across our entire city and
Beyond
in grieving this shocking and painful
loss of your lives
the governor myself
we visited in the hospital this morning
with
several of their families to offer them
our support
and our love
during these Unthinkable day
we will continue to offer our support
and love and anything else we can
provide to help them
we were also there along with several of
my colleagues from Metro Council
to thank and support the officers of
lmpd
for there who will heroic work
today
and every day
to say thank you to the new graduating
class
who was there to support
their colleague officer will
he continues to fight for his life
let's be clear about what this was
this was an evil Act of targeted
violence
and to add to that tragedy
a few blocks away shortly after this
happened
another man lost his life
and a woman was shot in a completely
different Act of targeted violence
two incidents appear to be entirely
unrelated
but they both took lives
they both leave people scarred grieving
and angry
I share all of those feelings myself
right now
this is really difficult for all of us
across the entire city
to process and accept
I ask that we respect the needs
of the families and loved ones of the
people
whose lives were lost today
and the people whose lives will never be
the same
I'm a Survivor of a workplace shooting
to the people who survived
whether you are physically hurt or not
I know that you're hurting too
we are here for you
as well
to the survivors and the families our
entire city
is here to wrap our arms around you
we've set up a family assistance center
through the Red Cross
to provide support and services
to those families today
and in the coming
days weeks and months ahead that we know
will be challenging
to provide you with whatever you need to
deal with the trauma of this moment
the same applies to our police officers
and First Responders
our city is here for everyone impacted
we are a strong City for
and we will be here for support
mentioned our lmpd officers went into
that building knowing that they were
risking their lives to say their lives
to save other lives and that's exactly
what they did
they exchanged gunfire with the shooter
the officer Wilt and his family
will continue to pray and support you
to the other two lmpd officers who were
injured thank you and all of your
colleagues for your service today
and every day
I also want to thank all of our other
first respondents
Fire EMS Jefferson County Sheriff state
and federal agencies that are helping us
at this time
and to Dr Smith to you and all of the
other doctors and nurses and team at
uofl health for your work today and
every lot and every day you too are
saving lives in our city and we thank
you
for the rest of us in our city
let's hold each other close
and provide Comfort where we can
that's what we've done in the past and
that's what we must continue to do now
we've already received offers of
assistance from people across this city
and Country
thank you
by the end of the day we'll be providing
specific information on how to provide
donations to those impacted today if you
would like we will also have more
information by the end of the day
about a community-wide
vigil
for the
targeted acts of violence that happened
today
and any day
in our city
we will continue to move forward with
strength
prayer with love support
and determination
thank you all now I'm going to turn it
over to Governor Andy beshear governor
okay
today is a tragic day in Louisville and
for the entire Commonwealth of Kentucky
acts of violence like this hurt they
tear at the fabric of who we are at our
society at our state
at our country
in this city
today I'm hurt
and I'm hurting
and I know so many people out there are
as well
we lost four children of God today
one of whom was one of my closest
friends
Tommy Elliott helped me build my law
career
help me become governor
gave me advice on being a good dad
it's one of the people I talk to most in
the world and very rarely what we're
talking about my job
he was an incredible friend
we also lost Julianna farmer Jim Tutt
Josh Barrett each amazing people whose
families grieved them whose Community
will mourn and will miss them these are
irreplaceable
amazing individuals had a terrible act
of violence tore from all of us
we also pray
for our lmpd officer and two others that
right now while perhaps stable are still
fighting for their lives with
a need for our care and yes for our
prayers because I believe
I believe
and I believe that prayers lift all of
us up and those families would
appreciate them
and while I heard today
while I will grieve when I'm able
I'm also grateful
I'm grateful for an incredibly quick
response from lmpd the Jefferson County
Sheriff's Office
Louisville fire and rescue Louisville
Metro EMS getting to this scene in three
minutes
I'm convinced say other people's lives
and I know say two other of my friends
what I received
incorrect information this morning I
thought was gone
and I've started to mourn
and now I know he's okay
and what I got to see in the ER
that while it's going to take him a
while to heal
so good to see my friend
see him there with his wife and know he
is still with us
I want to thank
KSP ATF FBI every single law enforcement
agency that is going to bring their
entire weight and their entire resources
to bear so that we know exactly what
happened in this situation
and you know there are more First
Responders than the ones we've listed
because the team at uofl hospital are
First Responders too
the first battle was stopping that
gunman
second is doing everything we can to
keep those that have been wounded alive
and I want to say to this good doctor
behind me and we have worked together
through pandemics and now this that I'm
really proud of what his team is doing I
was in a room where one of those
families that are rightfully worried got
an update and it was one that was
specific but also provided with
compassion
these doctors and nurses are fighting
for the lives of our friends
of our family and we are deeply grateful
to them
I think what we need most right now in a
word is love
I mean just love
love for these families
they're gonna need it I can tell you
I've talked to them
I'm very close with one of them they are
going to need that love
and we need love for each other
it seems like we argue so much
in this country so much anger
I still believe that love
and compassion and Humanity can lead us
to a better place
now this is hard it's really hard the
day after Easter
Now Easter is about a rebirth a better
world one where we're all supposed to
work together
to get there one that's supposed to
teach us love from a savior that came
I will fell in love with them not
because of his power but for his
compassion
and I believe what we can do whether
it's any faith or just your values is
ensure that today more than anything
is about these families it's about those
families that are afraid they're going
to lose their loved one about those that
have been through the worst and while
may have survived are going to Bear the
scars inside and outside today
it's got to be about them
the heroic actions of everybody who
responded and yes I know
in the days to come we'll talk about
issues
but I think the thing that people get
wrong after the most difficult of times
and days and as Governor I've had to see
a lot of them
is it today ought to be focused
well my friend
and on everybody else's friends and
loved ones that are no longer with us
my faith teaches me that while the body
is Mortal the soul is eternal
so I know that I will see Tommy again
and I know that
all of these families and friends in
this community
we will be reunited in a better place
without files
without the senselessness and hurt that
we feel today
we will get through this
get through this together it's the only
way
we'll March forward in My Hope
is that in honor of those that have
fallen today or that may still fall
we could be better
and we can do better
we care about love each other just a
little bit more
today
um
to honor those that have fallen and
asked so many families grieve I'm
ordering
our flags Statewide
fly
half staff until Friday
um
Friday evening
to make sure that we are paying tribute
in every single part of this
Commonwealth to those that we have lost
We Are One Commonwealth
United with the city
United with these families but we've had
to do a lot in these last three years is
wrap our arms around each other
and we need to do it here
thank you
well and next
um we're going to hear from Dr Smith who
is leading an incredible team try to
make sure as many of those that were
harmed in this incident get through it
and let me just again say that he and
his Hospital have my full support and
confidence I've seen it firsthand what
they're doing is nothing short of
amazing and listen I know they're going
to do their best
and while we don't know what that
outcome can be we ought to be
appreciative then for doing their very
best
well thank you very much for that
uh as of reported
um this morning University of Louisville
Hospital received nine patients uh three
of which are currently in critical
condition
uh the three that are in critical
condition did require operative care and
from our trauma team and our Emergency
Department Services
we were able to release three and three
are currently still in our hospital with
non-life-threatening injuries
um I want to say thank you to uh
Louisville as a city I want to say thank
you to our police officers and our EMS
services
I have no doubt in my mind that they
save lives today I I think they as many
in the health care industry have been
through a difficult time recently
but they have stood up and stand up
for Louisville and the people of
Louisville constantly and they have our
thanks from U of L health
I also want to thank my nurses in the
emergency department
my physicians in the emergency
department
through all of this they remained as the
professionals that they are
they were able to care for a large
number of people coming in severely
injured in a very short period of time
we were able to get them to the services
they need
and as of now no one has arrived at the
hospital has expired
now I do not know what the days ahead
will be
I do know that they are still injured
but I also know that we are all those
billions
and it doesn't matter where we come from
it does not matter who we look like
we are all part of Louisville
lmpd EMS uofl health we are here for
everyone
and so I would like to thank everyone
who's helped us today I would like to
thank all the well wishes I've received
both personally and from our Health Care
system from around the country
support for people who have been through
this around the country and know the
pain
that my team is currently facing know
the pain that the lmpd and EMS teams are
currently facing
and will be with us because as again we
are all dual billions
um
I want to thank everyone again for what
they do for us every day we are
a wonderful and integral part of this
city and I am proud to be part of uofl
health and I'm proud to be part of uofl
Hospital
um so with that thank you and I'll turn
it over for questions
thank you very much Dr Smith we're
prepared to take a few questions from
the media
I believe everyone who had had surgery
today are still sedated no one is
currently awake but still very early in
this process for many of that
information really the next 24 hours for
all involved in this who required an
operation are going to be the critical
time period for us to understand really
how well they're going to recover from
this acute part of their overall care
they've got long roads ahead of them but
if we can get through it 24 hours then
we will take another 24 hours and we
will keep doing that until they get out
of the hospital
the average person does that mean
gunshot wounds can that be considered
non-life-threatening in this case
yes you can have gunshot ones that are
non-life threatening correct
we had we treated a total of five
gunshot wounds today from this scene
an officer was shot in their head and
then ultimately you hear that for now he
is stable but um
put your thoughts there
that is one of the worst moments within
any police chief's tenure being in this
position
to hear that any of your officers have
been injured in any kind of way but
critically injured
but it's also too it rubs me and it just
rocks my world to have anybody
being injured and losing their life and
so I am just truly
I have so much respect for the families
because they were still
present and we're very appreciative of
what was done and how lmpd responded
today
and they were actually embracing me as I
was embracing them
but let me say this the evil that took
place today we shouldn't hear the tears
that were coming out
from these families
and that right there sticks because they
are Weeping because someone decided
that they wanted to take life today
and so but with that I'm very grateful
and hopeful and I'm thankful to the
doctor for stabilizing
um so many that could have possibly lost
their life
that's a gun
what exact type gun was used and where
the shooter died if you know that at
this point I don't know whether the
shooter got the weapon from but I just
can say that it was a rifle used as I
mentioned earlier about what happened
inside the gun building prior to the
shooting this morning repeat that again
can you talk more about what happened
inside the Bank building prior to the
shooting again this is an ongoing
investigation and again as like the
governor governor has stated we want to
focus in on the families we want to
focus in right now what happened and as
this investigation continues to unfold
then we'll be able to reveal a little
bit more
is that stuff going to be taken down and
was he communicating on Instagram before
this incident I will say this that the
suspect was live streaming and
unfortunately that's that's tragic to
know that that incident was out there
and captured
um and so we're hopeful that we can have
that that incident removed has the home
of this shooter in this case been
searched have you discovered anything
manifests to the things again it's still
ongoing within this investigation still
unfolding and so I don't want to get
into any additional particulars at this
time
was
have you had any encounters with the
Departments a hidden tax from my
understanding right now preliminarily
wise that may change but my
understanding we have not had any prior
engagement with this individual
he worked at Old National Bank and so I
am assuming right now that he was the
citizen of Louisville
and they want to get into particulars on
that investigation portion of it but
again is ongoing so I respect your
questions
turquoise of the bay yes yes
thank you yes
thank you yes chief
my shopping
list yes sir
yes sir
I'm not familiar with any other
additional security with that inside the
location but again let's focus back on
this initial incident right here that we
were responded in a timely quick fashion
and we stopped the threat so that no
additional loss of life could be taken
we will continue we will continue to
provide updates as we have more
information this has been a very active
day where we are as the governor and
chief said we are using every resource
available from local state and federal
agencies to provide all of these answers
to the entire Community to the loved
ones who lost victims today and so we
are going to get back to work we will
continue to keep you all up to date as
we have more information thank you all
very much
uh we will we will let you know when the
next update is going to be shortly thank
you thank you